[Music]  forests have always burned  and they always will it's a love nature  it's a crown fire we can't stop it  everything will be lost that simple  you're taking me along so that i'd fly  with you see a real fire and realize  it's no joke am i getting that right  pops  catch a burn and run off home that type  of thing  i can see that you're scared hello roma  and what if i send those planes out  there for nothing  who's going to answer for that i will if  nobody else will  if these aren't your own people  then who are  we're getting the villagers evacuated  and ready to hit the road  the road's on fire  i'll be just fine  i promise  take her lower come on come on  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you